[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
oh is there mountains of news today
more rakes that they are stepping on
[Music]
more Hunter Biden's laptops [__]
oh man
they're never gonna stop with the laptop
talk are they it's not gonna end oh
James Comer has asked if he has evidence
if the president United States and his
vault involved in any of the schemes
that he's claiming is the reason why
they want to impeach him he can't give
an answer and when asked where his
evidence comes from hey he found it only
interwebs well God damn I did my own
research on Facebook but Facebook says
get me a [__] break man they have no
none zero zilch not a single shred of
evidence that any transaction that they
talked about this morning is a result of
a crime not one and this is all in the
distraction folks every single bit of
this is a distraction
from the fact that this morning
representative George Santos has been
been indicted on 13 felony counts the
same moment
that Donald Trump was found guilty
of being a sexual assaulter and a
defamer yesterday
as he gives his whiny little [__] video
from Mar-A-Lago yes we're gonna show
that I don't know how we're gonna get to
all this today really honestly I have no
clue we only have two hours
and of the last few days we've been
talking about butt deodorant and a few
things so if we get off track oh baby oh
baby we're not gonna get to the news but
I'm gonna try to get to every single
piece of this news because there's a lot
of news being lost Tucker Carlson isn't
back maybe I don't um oh yeah he's
irrelevant Dr Carlson has filed a
lawsuit against Fox News for fraud good
luck
good luck I would imagine that Fox News
um
acts that contract in the proper way to
escort Tucker off of their platform so
they had creative control back of the 8
PM spot and that honestly is the debate
to have here really honestly is are we
going to have more news content where
someone has complete creative control
and frame it up as news
and call it news news is not
entertainment
okay it's not this is entertainment this
if you want the liberal media you're
looking at it folks right here on the
Tony Michaels podcast I am the liberal
media
and that news I mean
it may be news to the left on how to do
this and that may be a thing it pisses
him off and people get mad when I say
[__] like that that the left doesn't
know how to do media they just don't
they don't
I'm sorry they they [__] suck at it
they don't know how to get people's
emotions raised they don't have people
to get people's antennas up to listen
listen these are these are very
important debates that we're going to
have
over the next couple decades I'm saying
it's gonna take 20 years to short some
of this [__] out
these people aren't just gonna go crawl
back underneath their rocks tomorrow
it's clear they're in it for the Long
Haul
so we have to have we have to have a
media that is biased towards the truth
towards the American people and what
they want and the mind not not the
minority ideology that has control over
State houses who has control over our
house of representatives because of
gerrymandering no we need to have
liberal media biased media in this
country
that is biased towards I don't know like
rights Freedom Liberty
um you know equality Equity that would
be nice
that would be nice
tonight there's more news speaking of
the media speaking of the news media uh
everyone thinks CNN is some sort of
liberal Bastion over there
clearly it is not they're gonna be
promoting a sexual and
a convicted sexual abuser people don't
like these words yesterday I want to do
a Twitter space
and they were like it's he's he's not
guilty the word isn't guilty Tony it's
libel I'm like number one eyes not an
attorney so eyes don't give two [__]
about your semantics I don't care what
you're calling it what you want to call
it and what the news has to report it as
he's [__] guilty dummy you think
Americans are running around going yeah
he he wasn't guilty he was liable
get the [__] out of here listen all at
the same time Maga and the trumploodites
and I'm talking about the people who are
pushing narrative in this country they
do two things at once which is [__]
just astounding it's amazing actually
like and they're doing it this morning
they're like how dare Hunter Biden the
child of a president benefit financially
from foreign governments
forget about Jared Kushner who is
actually a [__] advisor of the White
House who flew on Air Force One with the
president as part of his [__]
Entourage and received two billion
dollars from the Saudis get the [__] out
of here
they do this thing they do this thing
where they they gotta have both both
sides of the fence you know what I mean
they got to straddle the [__] fence
it's it's amazing really when you see it
it's it's incredible it's incredible it
it really is something a sight to see
and there and yesterday they did it all
too well oh man oh man yesterday this is
all [__]
you can't use the word guilty you can't
use that word guilty Tony the [__] I
can't No One's Gonna use the word libel
no one no one gives a [__] if you don't
want people to use the word libel either
that's what the narrative is that's what
the message is
really honestly there's a lot of
Americans who are ignorant enough that
think Trump was found guilty of the [__]
he was arrested four weeks ago
I I'm not kidding you
I'm not kidding you and that's what they
do is they believe they believe that
America is smart enough to understand
their stupid [__] plot lines but
they're ignorant enough to believe their
stupid [__] plot lines are you
following me it's really weird stuff
it's really weird especially when you
see the plot lines slip through their
fingers like this Bud Light thing right
they keep bringing this up they keep
bringing this up Lauren bobert brought
this up this morning in a hearing
Anheuser-Busch and I look listen Bud
Light isn't going anywhere neither is
anheus or bush you [__] boneheads
it's not going anywhere you may have
infected one month of sales but when we
get to the end of the year and we see
what Bud Light sales are you're gonna
[__] your [__] britches okay people
are still drinking Bud Light even the
people who hate Dylan Mulvaney who are
[__] bigots are still drinking Bud
Light because it's what's in their gas
stations is what's in their [__]
grocery stores and it's the cheap [__]
what what don't you understand about
drinking beer it's to get drunk as cheap
as you possibly can what do you think
Bud light's for this is the dumbest [__]
ever
that they keep trying to mold and shape
these stupid [__] culture War
narratives like the narrative that oh
man all these charges that are that the
34 charges felonies that the grand jury
indicted Donald Trump on that's all
political that's all political
and and they need to be washed away and
this is so ridiculous and Alvin Bragg
needs to resign yet James Comer this
morning levels levels charges against
against the president of the United
States without any evidence and they say
this a lot right this was trending on
Twitter bidenfamily Biden family Biden
family Biden family Biden family Biden
family the reason why they're saying
Biden family is because it's it's people
who had the last name Biden who received
these payments that they claim
are evidence of crime which they don't
have evidence of
and that's why they have to say Biden
family because there is no payment made
to
the big guy Joe Biden you [__]
boneheads man I I have to tell you that
they're gonna jump the shark here and
they're going to continue to do this
[__] you know call it rake stepping call
it fleece planting Jumping the Shark
whatever you want to call it they're
going to continue to do this and the
reason why is because they're losing
they're losing their culture wars
they're absolutely losing it and we
should not stand in the way as they lose
those Wars we should not stand in their
way let them lose those Wars that's
exactly what we should do is let them
yell and scream
their bigotry out loud and just and just
keep holding them accountable in every
single measure and keep engaging in our
democracy and we have to [__] show up
to vote and not only that we have to
continue to pound the telephone
um I caught I made a call out the other
day after the mass shooting in Allen
Texas for everyone to call their
Congress people people were excited and
I I think a lot of folks in the audience
here decided to make that move
and to politely call their their
Congressman their United States Senator
their state reps and say hey and that's
enough [__] enough's enough now is it
going to work tomorrow no but that's the
whole point of democracy that's the
whole entire point is yeah it's
difficult it's hard to make change it is
that's what it should be we we should
have to work hard to make change in this
country and when we do we should protect
that change as well and we we should
work just as hard to protect it and yeah
it's it's tough that's because
liberalism isn't isn't the the [__]
principle weakness it's the principle of
strength an autocracy is the principle
of [__] weakness that's what Ron
DeSantis is trying to sell that's what
Lauren bobert is trying to sell that's
what Donald Trump is trying to sell just
let me handle all your problems let me
let me use my pen and my power to get
rid of all your problems whether it's
Dylan Mulvaney on Bud Light cans or
Disney having having The Little Mermaid
be black whatever it is whatever it is
whatever it is the authoritarians want
to use the stroke of their pen and they
want to just snap their fingers and Bam
your problems are solved that's the easy
way out don't you see that
how easy is it just about well dumb
dumbly
say you know what I'm just gonna believe
everything this person believes I'm just
gonna believe they're the Messiah and
they're the one that's supposed to be in
charge and they were sent here by God
and they're going to make every decision
for us and all those decisions are going
to be correct and doesn't sound like
democracy to me it sounds like autocracy
to me and that's what they want
but that's why they're leveling these
arguments that's why they're distracting
from one of their members that they had
to have to make Kevin McCarthy speaker
that they continue to have to have
to make sure to make sure that they can
impeach Joe Biden
on charges of what because Hunter Biden
took money from somebody okay and and
what else what else
and here's their strategy
here's the strategy for the election
folks because that's the most important
thing here and you are the most
important jury
in this trial
of our democracy
what they want to have happen is to
impeach Joe Biden because Donald Trump
is convinced that he lost because he was
impeached and if he can just impeach Joe
Biden then he will win that is what this
is and if you don't see that James Comer
and Jim Jordan and all these [__]
House Republicans are absolutely the lap
dogs of Donald J Trump you are a [__]
bonehead if you're out there like if you
can't see the corruption where Hunter
Biden who isn't in the White House who
is the son of a president and at the
time of vice president and a former vice
president is taking money I mean you
know I don't begrudge Hunter Biden for
taking money you would take money right
you would take money right
if you had a name like Biden where where
your dad was a United States senator for
decades he was the vice president former
vice president now the president
you would take money absolutely you wait
is it fair probably not that certain
families are afforded certain things in
this country Maybe not maybe that's not
fair but you would do it you certainly
would capitalize on your name
and to think to think that none of this
would have happened if if Joe Biden
would have been president of the United
States you people are dumb as dog [__]
or that he wouldn't have happened if he
wasn't vice president he was he was he
was a [__] sitting United States
Senator what the [__] are you talking
about
you don't think that that some power
came with the name Biden
and then and then the right Wingers
conflated with well well uh then uh what
if what if
what if Donald Trump Jr
um he went over and he got special
treatment I mean he did and we said that
we said that and we also said it about
Ivanka and Jared Ivanka Trump with the
last name Trump
she received countless dozens of patents
from China
after she went and visited China with
her dad who was the president
[__] out of here man you're not fooling
anybody and this idea that they're gonna
Frame Up The Narrative that somehow the
Biden family is corrupt and the Biden
family is a crime family you people you
people you mogulanites just don't
understand that the country already sees
what is in front of them they already
know the Trump family is corrupt they
already see what is happening
we watched as the guy tried to overturn
the [__] government of the United
States and become the dictator they know
that now
that's our part of the narrative that's
already part of the story okay
it's not [__] hidden
so either do one or two things either
come out and say look
we don't care if Republicans commit
crime we don't give a [__] we don't care
whether it's George Santos or Donald
Trump Ivanka Jared Donald Trump Jr we
don't give a [__]
if Republicans commit crime the only
crime we care about
is that the scent just the hint maybe
the the the
visual of what could possibly be crime
from Democrats that's the only ones we
care about and that's what we want to
weaponize is because it's always
projection
always always with these [__] idiots
it's always projection and that's what
they're looking for
is they're looking for the American
people to believe
here it is they're looking for the
American people to believe that every
single every single legal woe that
Donald Trump has is all every single bit
of it is all [__] it's all level
against them because it's all politics
and it's all a Witch Hunt and it's all
fake news
but they can't provide a shred of
evidence
that Joe Biden committed crime with
these transactions but they want the
American people to believe that that was
the reason why these transaction happens
is because Joe Biden is a criminal
people are [__] dumb as dog [__]
people people listen I don't I don't
know if you [__] mogulate to know
this most people don't even know who
their governor is
they don't know who represents them in
Congress
it's not because they don't give a [__]
about their lives
it's because they're ignorant of civics
and how democracy works it's not that
they can't understand it it's not that
they're not smart enough to understand
and distinguish truth and fact and
fiction that you're trying to level that
you're trying to push into the into the
the the [__] society
as your [__] excuse the word trumped
up narrative
they're not dumb
yeah they're ignorant but it's only
because they don't know
but you think you think a side-by-side
comparison this country
is is going to is going to believe your
narrative that everything that is
leveled against Trump is fake and
[__] and a Witch Hunt and you keep
saying these words they're not my words
you keep saying this [__]
all the while when you are leveling
allegations that are completely basis in
any fact of what you're trying to
measure
that Joe Biden needs to be impeached and
imprisoned and so does Hunter
if that's the case then fine whatever
let the [__] chips fall but you don't
have the chips
and the American people aren't that
[__] dumb I mean the American people
are uneducated folks we have an
education problem in this country
but that's what breeds their ignorance
it's not what breeds their stupidity
it's not it I mean they're stupid people
in this country any country really I
mean
there's people who believe the Earth is
flat
and that's not because of their
ignorance
it's not
that's not ignorance folks that's
[__] just stupidity
ignorance is when you are not aware of
something that is a fact when you get
the fact in front of you you can make a
a very critical thinking decision of
what is that fact it's not hard it's not
complicated that's why Donald Trump lost
my almost 8 million [__] votes in
2020.
the facts were laid out and they were
bare
and yesterday we watched
as the access Hollywood tape finally
finally
was used as evidence that yes
he does assault women he grabs them by
the [__] that is what he does he proved
it in his deposition when he said well I
mean
for millions of years people people knew
that men could just do that stars could
do that you could just grab them by the
[__] so I mean that's what I would do
that's what he basically said in his
deposition what is so surprising
that that led to them convicting him of
guilt that's right I said a guilt sue me
sue me for libel and defamation would
you please
someone said that to you they're like oh
anyone who tis Donald Trump is guilty
is is gonna be sued for defamation and
libel okay go for it [__] do it he's
guilty he [__] grabbed her by the
[__] she went to court federal court
said yes he did he said not only did I
not do that she's disgusting she's ugly
and I would never rape her if I was
gonna rape someone to be someone way
better than what she was literally when
he said and stuck in the court and she
won
and she won he lost he's guilty of doing
what she accused him of doing which is
defaming her and grabbing her by her
genitals so you can pound sand got it
and this is this this Joe Biden stuff
this morning it's laughable laughable
because they had to rush to the
microphone to protect Donald Trump to
change the narrative well we're not
going to let him we're not going to let
him because tonight CNN is going to
promote a sexual abuser right there on
stage I can't wait I can't wait to see
if they actually ask the right questions
if they ask the correct questions the
questions that ever all Americans
wanting to know
did you grab her by the [__] that is
what Americans looking for folks I don't
know I don't I listen I know it sounds
like I'm advocating for CNN to have this
town hall and I am
I absolutely am
I mean I don't think I think CNN should
lead in with hey
I know this seems weird that we're gonna
have someone who's just convicted uh
being a sexual assaulter and a defamer
and a liar a lying sack of [__] on our
Channel but we want you to see how much
of us a bonehead a sexual assaulter and
a liar he really is so here here he is
Donald J Trump everyone
give him a round of applause folks
there's no better disinfectant than
sunlight none especially with this
[__] because I'm going to show
you this the video today of of the
little commentary that he gave after
yesterday's verdict holy [__] [__] I
mean he is just [__] his diapers
and I can't wait I can't wait oh man
it's gonna be so sweet
when finally Willis and Jack Smith
makes their move on that [__] and grabs
Donald Trump by his freedom all right
everyone if you want to make sure to
stay in tune with the prosecutors
grabbing Donald Trump by his freedom
make sure to not miss a single episode
here on the Tony Michaels podcast uh
subscribe here on YouTube and while
you're here right now subscribe on
YouTube hit the Subscribe button also
download every single episode on Apple's
Spotify and Google it's free over there
to download if you're on Facebook or
have a Facebook account you can watch it
over there as well at the Tony Michaels
you can also watch it on Twitch
it's a great way to give you us monetary
support on the show without costing you
a single nickel here's how it works if
you have an Amazon Prime account
you can link that Prime account to your
Twitch account I actually have the
instructions on how to do it on my
website you just go to
thetonymichaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com scroll down just a bit it
says link Amazon and twitch you go on
there it'll do it for you go right into
that link you you link your Amazon Prime
account your Twitch account and you get
one free subscription with your Prime
account you give us that subscription on
Twitch and we get a couple bucks every
month and don't forget to renew it every
single month that's how it works it's a
pain in the ass but it's free money
meaning it's free for you to give us
money here at the show by subscribing to
the twitch Channel over on Twitch with
your Amazon Prime account and I want to
thank everyone who is doing that who has
been giving us the subscriptions who has
been renewing their subscriptions uh we
just get a few of them just in the last
few hours over there I also want to
mention that even if you're not a prime
user if you're not an Amazon Prime user
you can still go follow us on Twitch for
free it doesn't cost anything to follow
and watch the show over there but we get
a few bucks if you give us that
subscription uh to your with your Amazon
Prime account on our Twitch account and
we get a little bit of monetary support
which is very very much appreciated we
thank you so so much here on the Johnny
Michaels podcast for that holy moly
there's huge news so here's what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna go to a break when we
come back we're gonna get into the [__]
list right into it we're gonna go to
some of these clips some of this news
hope we gave Sanchez will join us right
away everyone stick around we'll be
right back right after this
[Music]
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that I'm struggling with I
chose Babble mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome welcome back to
the show
oh boy
[Music]
George Santos is at the top of the list
so is Kevin McCarthy uh I don't know if
Kevin McCarthy's responded to this or
not let's let's go take a look at the
George Santos at the George's Sanchez is
this his mugshot what the [__] come on
no that can't be is that it I don't [__]
I don't know
George Santos surrendered himself this
morning
[Music]
um
yeah 13 felony charges I don't know if
you um if you heard about this uh George
Santos has been under federal
investigation for quite some time
um uh Gabe Sanchez talked about this I
think last week where he had actually
settled a case with the Brazilian
prosecutors and it looks like now maybe
because of that or I'm not real sure
um what the doj's motivation to bring
these charges now but they brought
um 13 charges money laundering uh fraud
after public funds and false statements
to the House of Representatives which
the Republicans claim there's some sort
of Ethics investigation into
um into George Santos too I don't know
how far along that is but here's here's
the here's the number counts uh seven
counts of wire fraud uh three counts of
money laundering one count of theft of
public funds and two counts of making
material false statements uh to the
House of Representatives and so George
Santos George Santos [__] around and
he's gonna find out now let me tell you
something I that's a lot of counts uh
against George Santos and if you want to
see the um here is the
here's the actual indictment here uh
with the counts and I I pulled this from
Kyle Chaney Kyle Chaney does a great job
making sure some of these links get onto
um
oh [__] uh some of these links get onto
there's just so much news happening okay
um
so you see here the defendant and his
legal name on this indictment is George
Anthony devolder Santas and we know you
can see that here so now we know
George Santos's real name well yeah I
guess at least his indicted name that's
the one thing I pull from this right and
they say
oh man on the official indictment they
don't even know who this [__] is
look at this [__] it says the United
States of America against George Anthony
demola Santos otherwise known as George
Santos
can we use emojis on legal documents now
I think we should I think we should be
able to use emojis right or like George
Santos I don't know I don't know who
this guy is who knows who this
[__] is oh my God what an
[__] George Santos is
so again George Santos turns himself
into the eastern district of New York
and this morning and self surrenders to
receive his arraignment of his
indictment now I I will tell you that
um to give you an idea George Santos
will be released of his own recognance
so you'll see later on uh Today George
Santos will appear uh out of the
courthouse and he will not have uh they
may put an ankle monitor on but I doubt
it he's a member of Congress they
probably won't put an ankle monitor on
him he'll just walk out and he'll be
arraigned and he would have done his
pre-trial work because you gotta you
gotta go in you gotta do like a survey
they question you really got drug
problems you got alcohol problems if
you're committed crime before pass blah
blah blah because they're they're
working up like the what your what Your
pre-trial is going to look like or
whether you're going to be on house
arrest or you know what what these
conditions are they're going to drug
test you that sort of thing so they do
all that it's all typical procedure but
you'll see George Santos emerge out of
the courthouse
and George Santos
um well
will be on release of his own recognance
for at least a couple years
um he he I now my guess is is that the
Republican party is is gonna back him I
have no idea I don't know he's already
announced that he's gonna run right
um Beth asked here is Santos going to be
forced to resign well I mean that's a
good question I mean he can resign
tomorrow or today if he wants to he can
say you know this is a distraction from
the Congress blah blah blah
people my district deserve actual
representation not someone who's
distracted by a 13 count felony
indictment or federal felony indictment
and he can move along
now they can't
um I mean the Congress can can expel him
and they can remove him uh with the
Ethics Committee which but the
Republicans are in charge of that so
today when when Republicans are yelling
and screaming about ethics and political
ethics and politicians with ethics here
they have George Santos the [__]
quintessential
picture perfect
example of Republican corruption and
Republican lies and they're just going
to be like George who who's this Santos
character you talk about we we want we
want Hunter Biden's laptop okay Hunter
binds laptop are the only words that we
want to talk about today because we do
not want to talk about Donald Trump
being found guilty of sexually
assaulting Eugene Carroll and we
definitely don't want to talk about
George Santos 13 felony federal counts
we just don't want to do that
so that's one of the distractions so
Beth your question is
yes but I don't think they're going to
I don't I mean do you see the
Republicans kicking this [__]
out I don't see it they need Kevin
McCarthy needs this some [__]
Kevin McCarthy needs George the criminal
Santa's he needs him he [__] needs
him how else is he going to get because
think about this
okay you put this
in um let's let's say we clean this off
for a bit
George Santos is forced to resign our
Kevin McCarthy asked him to resign he
does that
the governor of New York is the one who
gets to appoint that member of Congress
in the interim do you think do you think
the Democratic governor of New York's
gonna gonna appoint a republican
congressperson [__] no
hails to the no
and matter of fact the Democratic party
is going to push the governor of New
York to try to select the most electable
incumbent
for that interim seat for the meantime
and I don't know the actual the um the
like the timeline but it's possible that
New York would have a special election
this year for that seat
and Republicans don't want that either
and the reason why Republicans don't
want that is because now they have to
show their derelict of Duty of records
are
holding up George Anthony devolder
Santos
and making him a congressperson and keep
defending him in Congress so we'll see
and maybe we'll get uh it's possible
that we'll get footage before the show
ends here if George Santos leaving uh
the courthouse that is a possibility I'm
not sure what time uh his arraignment
was
I have no idea
um just sometime later today and it's
probably they just have to get a
magistrate available to do his
arraignment and they will rein him in
court so my guess is he's sitting being
interviewed
as we speak
poor George Santas oh poor George poor
Georgie Boy
okay so let's go to the Tucker Carlson
news because there is Tucker Carlson is
that you missed it yesterday I'm sure
Tucker Carlson gave a video I have not
watched it yet I'm not [__] you
I usually try to watch these videos but
I did not watch this um
video from Tucker Carlson he came out
yesterday on Twitter he posted a video
here it is uh let's watch it's like
three minutes long and let's see if we
can stomach this let's see how much we
can get through let's listen
hey it's Tucker Carlson the offender of
people all right that's enough no I'm
just kidding I'm just kidding I I do
want to hear this and the reason why is
because of how [__] Irrelevant this
is again this is one of the last times I
would say this is one of the last times
that I will show a video of Tucker
Carlson without it having actual
relevance in the news because Tucker
Carlson is now irrelevant the other
reason why Tucker Carlson is so
irrelevant in this moment and what this
video is depicting of his irrelevance is
he's tying his wagon to eat are trying
to tie his wagon to Elon Musk and I
don't I don't know if you've been paying
attention for the last year but Elon
Musk has not had great success in PR he
just hasn't and he hasn't had great
success in making money he's lost a
shitload of it in the last I mean he's
really good at losing [__] money in
the last year let me tell you something
if there was like the richest man in the
world but the opposite like the guy who
loses the most [__] money not makes
the most money but loses the most
[__] money it would be Elon Musk you
could almost make the case that Elon
Musk is a bigger loser than Donald Trump
and Tucker Carlson has hitched his wagon
to both these [__]
oh man you can't make this [__] up I
don't get to make it up I don't make it
up I just I just [__] come here and
talk about it talk about the [__] that's
at me what do you want me to do what do
you want me to do
and let's listen to what Tucker's plan
is to not be irrelevant and good luck
say the news is full of lies but most of
the time that's not exactly right much
of what you see on television or read
the New York Times is in fact true in
the literal sense it could pass one of
the media's own fact checks lawyers
would be willing to sign off on it in
fact they may have but that doesn't make
it true it's not Jesus Christ see see
this is this is the stupid [__] this is
the dumb stupid [__] that the media does
and again this is why I say the left
wing needs someone like us
that's that that's what I'm saying
stop with all the [__] stop with all
the [__] data in the polls No One
Believes that [__] even if it's true
they don't believe that garbage just
like they don't believe the queuing on
stuff most people don't believe that
[__] garbage on Facebook they just
don't it's just your Uncle Earl that is
all upset about it because he's sitting
in his [__] recliner watching people
like Tucker Carlson for years on end
let's keep going not true at the most
basic level the news you consume is a
lie a lie of the stealthiest and most
Insidious kind facts have been withheld
on purpose along with proportion and
perspective okay so again he's doing the
same old propaganda [__] that he always
does this is what he does this is how he
does it this is how he attracts his
audience of people who don't trust the
media I mean you can trust the media or
you cannot trust the media whatever fine
but it doesn't mean that the media I I
criticize the media all the time and the
reason why is because how they frame the
argument and that both sides are the
same because they're trying to appear
unbiased to what the truth the [__] out
of here man and this is the reason why
Tucker Carlson exists in this space in
the first place is because all he's
trying to do is is to just make sure
that there's certain people out there
that don't believe the news so that way
they'll believe him [__] out of here man
keep going let's keep hearing his
nonsense and how he's going to be on
Twitter that's the result of this you
are being manipulated how does that work
let's see if I tell you that a man has
been unjustly arrested for armed robbery
that is not strictly speaking a lie he
may have been framed at this point
there's been no trial so no one can
really say
but if I don't mention the fact that the
same man has been arrested for the same
crime six times before am I really
informing you no I'm not oh my God see
and then the anecdotal [__] that these
[__] idiots do again I was in this
space this morning and Jim Baff or path
or whatever the [__] his name is I went
after him a bit in the space I don't
give a [__] [__] Jim [__] him Jim Jim
talked about how oh my God this Biden
stuff is so crucial oh my God we must
get to the bottom of these crimes that
we don't have evidence of and you
liberals need to stop poo-pooing this
I'm like you [__] you were the
one in the Twitter spaces three weeks
ago when Donald Trump was being
arraigned on 34 felony counts that the
Manhattan day D.A collected evidence
presented the evidence to a grand jury
the grand jury decided to indict him on
34 trucks 34 counts a business fraud
okay and it's not just transactions it's
not just clerical errors they were
intentionally hiding money the same
thing you're [__] accusing Joe Biden
of which you have no evidence of none
you just have oh we got transactions
look they were they were doing big
trains oh man oh man this one was ten
thousand this one was 50. these are Big
Numbers you just have transactions out
all you have that's all you got
[__] that's it you never have
any proof it's all [__] every single
[__] time
and Jim in the space I told him I said
you poop you poop poop Trump you poop
Trump so have the same [__]
energy man I don't give a [__] if Hunter
Biden is arrested tomorrow I don't give
a [__] I don't care matter of fact I'll
talk about it here on the show I don't
give a [__]
if Hunter Biden is arrested or not he's
not gonna be he's not gonna be indicted
they've already tried this they've
already tried it he's already paid
several [__] tax penalties to the IRS
for for his clerical errors on his
[__] taxes and yes there is a
two-tier justice system in this country
and yes it is it is the Republicans who
are scared that their two-tier justice
system is not going
to protect them anymore
just like Tucker Carlson is mad that his
little media Empire is crumbling out
from underneath him so he's blaming the
media for his [__] problems I'm
misleading you and that's what the news
media are doing in every story that
matters you know what's funny up until
what a week ago what did this guy was
the [__] news media
he was on he listen this guy was the
newsman this [__] was on the 8
PM spot on Fox News
cable news networks the number one Cable
News Network as far as as far as viewers
Fox News do you know the hour the hour
that was the most viewed hour
in every [__] weekday on Fox News it
was Tucker Carlson's show this guy was
the [__] news media
he was it you [__] piece of trash
every day of the week every week yeah we
know you did an assistant [__] you
wouldn't know 30 years in the middle of
it yeah
the best you can hope for in the news
business at this point is the freedom to
tell the fullest truth that you can but
there are always limits and you know
that if you bump up against those limits
often enough you will be fired for it
that's not a guess it's guaranteed every
person who works in English language
media understands that the
English did you notice that English
language media I haven't watched this
glitch this is great English like what
do you mean like unlike Uh Russian media
hahaha
I mean we all know that Decker Carlson
was making content just for Russian TV
alone
and goddamn this [__] guy rule of
what you can't say defines everything
it's filthy really and it's utterly
corrupting you can't have a free Society
if people aren't allowed to say what
they think is true set such [__]
dude you [__] spouted off your mouth
with a [__] contract that gave you
creative control that let you say
anything you want whenever you wanted
and you thought it was without
consequence but it's not
your free speech is not without
consequence you white privilege fragile
men need to [__] get it through your
thick ass cracker heads
your freedom of speech does not come
without consequence you dumb sons of
[__] including Tucker Carlson
it doesn't come without it stop acting
like you get to say whatever you want
whenever you want and no one can do
anything about it
you defamed Dominion Fox News continued
to defame dominion and they were gonna
win that is why Fox News settled for 800
million dollars that is why they fired
Tucker Carlson because they wanted
creative control back of their 8 PM slot
it's not rocket science it's not hard to
understand
it's not that Tucker wasn't doing a good
job of [__] brainwashing people he
was certainly doing a great job of that
just like he's doing in this video for
all his [__] sip ass cups
but it's about money
it's about money no one would want to be
tied to this [__] without
creative control
they just won't because he's a line sack
of racist bigoted piece of [__] let's
keep listening to the garbage speech is
the fundamental prerequisite for
democracy that's why it's enshrined in
the first of our constitutional amount
yes but it doesn't amazing tonight there
aren't many platforms left that allow
Free Speech the last big one remaining
in the world the only one is Twitter
where we there you have it there you
have it folks uh Twitter baby Twitter
Twitter
that's where he's going
now I wanna I wanna give you an idea
about Twitter and Periscope because I
went into the space yesterday
when they weren't talking about this and
I was asked about this because I have a
show ah that I air every day and I
actually broadcast to Twitter it's
broadcasting right now these some of
these people in this space didn't even
seem to know that you can broadcast to
Twitter
through periscope
now Periscope
um used to be a separate tool from and
I'm broadcasting right now hi do you see
me on Twitter
you can see me but I can't see you on
Twitter that's the why it sucks but
Periscope used to be a separate tool
from Twitter right used to be a totally
separate tool and then Twitter bought
Periscope and made Periscope an internal
tool but Periscope is still garbage it
is [__] gar badge and I know my
co-host will agree with me here he is
finally it's a piece of [__] it's a
piece of [__]
yeah I mean like I was in that you know
I was only in there last night in that
Twitter space for about 30 minutes were
you in there when I was in there when I
was talking no no because you went
before me yeah that's right because I
had I could only listen at one point and
then you went in and then um and then
when I went in uh Solomon was like hey
man you got a show let's hear what you
have to say I'm like what do you mean
what I had to say I broadcasted Twitter
every [__] day he's like what what
does it mean that you're gonna be able
to broadcast on Twitter and I'm like
what are you talking about I broadcast
Twitter a day it is garbage I said the
only reason why I do it is because I put
the YouTube link so they can click to go
to YouTube because no one wants to sit
and watch it on Twitter it's [__] but I
mean the the best way I can describe
Twitter is so you've got twitch which is
obviously it's built for more for
streaming than it is for playback video
right YouTube right right YouTube and
originally intended to be a playback
video but then they Incorporated
streaming made sense right
Twitter allows you to stream but the
look you can look at the highest
the you can look at
accounts that have the most followers
the most engagement and you'll probably
see similar type of behavior on videos
nobody stays for the full video unless
it's within two minutes or less people
do not have attention spans that short
and what you will find what what I
didn't catch it oh yeah so let me say it
again so but you you will see that
Twitter to I believe Twitter is the
human embodiment
or rather Twitter is like if ADHD and
eavesdropping had a [__] baby okay oh
really people do not have long attention
spans all right because especially on
Twitter yeah yeah yeah [__] crack you
got people that are so they're like oh
my God what's going on and they just
jump over to a new tweet well it's so
easy to scroll so so
let's dive into this a little bit and
then we'll get back to the Tucker
Carlson video because I I think this is
important and what these [__] these
people were talking about last night
because they try to get in Weeds that
don't exist right they're like oh well
Twitter Twitter's gonna be this and
Twitter's gonna be that I'm like you're
so full of [__]
the same way the same way that platforms
like Tick Tock claim to be one thing but
they're just one thing it is just one
thing it is just a feed of videos that
you you scroll up on and it works well
to keep people on that platform right
that's why that's why platforms like
Instagram platforms like Facebook in The
Meta Universe platforms like YouTube
have created reels because they want
that as part of their platform Twitter
doesn't have that at all there's no
infrastructure that that exists and it's
not it's not even
um how do I want to say this because
it's not it's not I guess it is kind of
a culture on Twitter because because
when you go to different social medias
there's a different again I think
culture is the wrong word
um maybe that is the right here describe
it and then I'll see if I can find them
well where it just it
dealing that you get like some people
prefer Twitter over Facebook Some people
prefer Facebook over Twitter and it may
be because of how you scroll how you
find information how information is
presented to you with the algorithm and
and and a certain group of people tend
to gravitate towards certain social
media platforms that's why we have so
[__] many of them I mean if if this
was all finite right we would have one
social media and it would be the king
and no one else could enter the market
but that's not the case do you mean like
uh
um
Like A vibe like a theme well that that
might be that might be it it might be
the vibe the feeling the the but you
know culture is I guess and all yeah I
guess that's the closest thing let me
see if there's a what's it but I mean it
just it it just seems to me that what
these people put their faith in Elon
Musk which is wow like right holy [__]
do you have any idea that he was the
richest man in the world until he became
the person who wants the most amount of
money in the least amount of time right
you're not understanding I mean this
moment the amount of people that were in
that space miles Ian Sean uh [__]
right [__] your sister
I could not remember what the name was
yesterday in the space because I wanted
to say it I was like ah [__] whatever
the point being oh yeah I did promise
you the next time I went in I'd call him
that yeah I didn't because he was he was
like because because I said my question
to Elon Musk because Solomon asked me a
question I said my my direct question
Elon Musk would be if he's listening
from one of his sock accounts in this
room wow one of my one of my questions
to him would be Are you seriously
thinking about building on top of
periscope which is absolutely garbage
and go from there are you talking about
building an entire infrastructure and
Ian's like oh he's going to build a tire
I'm like what what makes you say that
you you have no evidence of that other
than that's what you want because that's
what would because that's what would be
best here right yeah if if they really
wanted to do what what
um Elon is proposing as far as Tucker
Carlson where they're the app of
everything and they become the YouTube
now and The Tick Tock he wants I mean he
said you know he's like I want to be the
WeChat for the US which again not an
original idea it's taking someone else's
idea and then uh placing credit is
yourself on there right but and maybe
culture is the right word then when you
compare it in that form maybe I mean
maybe I don't know it's it's one of
those things here's the thing and I said
in the space last thing I was like from
a product development standpoint because
that's what my background is in right in
product design and product development
you have there's with any project really
with anything you do in life
there's uh uh here capitalism means
Americans can choose where and who we
Patron we hold the power turn these
fashionable again it pushes off that's
how we fight back into pocketbooks
that's true that's how you do it yeah
Amanda's got it right there and and to
that point is that that's what I was
trying to say about social medias that's
why we have all kinds of them because
the idea that there's no freedom of
speech is stupid it's really dumb we
have more speech now than we have ever
had in human history yeah more speeches
you want to know how much you want to
know how much well I'll go back to the
development side in a second but you
want to know how much free speech we
have you can lie about anything I mean
you know it there's consequences for it
can be yeah I mean look at George Santos
right like the guy lied about literally
every every aspect of his life
you know it it's totally fine it's
protected you can lie about these things
especially if you're uh a politician
which we know that they do
but there are going to be consequences
hopefully later down the line if
somebody decides to follow up but um
the thing I want to say about the
product development side and again any
project can be this way there are three
you know think of it like a Venn diagram
a triplet of Venn diagram he texted me
this yesterday right right and I and I
and I briefly mentioned yesterday
because that's the thing these [__]
idiots don't understand this right
especially from an entrepreneurial
standpoint like maybe some people I know
you know Mario's got uh he's an
entrepreneur and other things but
there's a with any project in life you
want to do not only just Tech or
whatever there's three circles Venn
diagrams there's good cheap and fast and
you can never have more than two and you
never want to compromise on good so it's
either cheap and fast and it's not good
it's either cheap and good but it's slow
because not fast uh it's either uh fast
and good and it's going to be expensive
because it won't be cheap right so you
have to realize that in here in that
Venn diagram where does spontaneously
combusting come in where does that oh
that would be trying to accomplish all
three and oh okay okay I'm just asking
because Elon Musk his Tesla is
spontaneously combusted yes Rockets
good right or you want to be fast and
cheap you cut Corners in either one of
these but the thing is at the end of the
day it's never going to play out how you
want and so what you see is that Elon
Musk whether he uses 2015 code of
periscope because that was the last time
it was touched right from 2015
if you use that fine that will get him
started however they have to go back
through and rethink the whole
architecture of how Periscope yes
developed [__] well because because the
idea of periscope was just to give an
eyeball right there was never there was
never in that product and in that
platform there was never this idea that
there was going to be this huge user
engagement it was just it was a user
just to watch a video live that was it
that was the whole because remember and
for those who don't know Periscope was
an independent app where you could live
stream be like hey this is what I'm
doing people can interact with it heart
heart they could comment and stuff you
could see people who joined and then
Twitter was like hey we want that live
streaming app we want to incorporate
that into our our Twitter app and the
experience they did that
but it wasn't really it was just like
maintained to make sure that it didn't
break the whole [__] app of Twitter
let me show you something right here
as we're speaking here is Periscope now
now it's an internal tool right right
because
um here I'll show it to you right on the
screen there we are there we are
streaming right now and it's going to do
the whole
and then once it gets caught up because
there is a latency Delay from where we
actually speak and then the words get
out into the Interwest and so what we're
going to see here is you know purely if
I was assessing this from a product
development standpoint
uh
uh you could work off Periscope code
again it's from 2015. no one's really
touched it it's shut down in 2021
officially even though you can still use
parts of it when you're live streaming
like this however it's it's how we push
with ourselves there's no feedback right
we can't see if people join or people
comment or people like on Twitter and
they dropped all those tools when was
that that was last year sometime wasn't
it
was it 2021 yeah we were having trouble
because we were having trouble
um with our software actually streaming
to Twitter where I couldn't actually get
because I still can't stream to our
podcast account I can stream to my
account and I'm not sure if there's some
sort of because that account was created
later or something I have no idea no
there's something about Periscope and
that's why you want to know you want to
know how deeply connected Periscope is
into here if you don't have Periscope
setup
uh well here I had a periscope account
and I was going through a bunch of
social media accounts and I was like I
don't use this disconnect disconnect
disconnect right I deleted my Periscope
account do you know what product it
directly affected inside of Twitter
spaces no they're [__] linked
underneath in the code they are linked
so the Periscope is spaces
Periscope is using spaces or sorry space
is using Periscope code okay so what's
happening underneath this is no wonder
it crashes all the time if you were to
happen to go into Periscope right now
and you were to move Periscope as an
account which I did which I don't know
maybe a few months ago uh I was like oh
what the [__] is this I don't need this
anymore so I deleted it right deleted my
account disconnected done then I tried
to join and go into Twitter spaces
nothing loaded it was all blank people
would send me an invite I click on it it
would show a blank screen so I was like
get the [__] out of here man so then I
was like oh that's weird and I had this
random thought like oh well maybe it's
somewhat connected to the fact that I
deleted Periscope so I had to go back in
and reconnect Periscope with my Twitter
account
boom and then it was working again Jesus
Christ so that's just to show you that
those there are things within that code
they're [__] Tangled so you have to
untangle them and decide how you want to
use them because what should happen is
again from product development
standpoint and Engineering you want to
Silo those things off and if you're like
hey look Periscope runs on this or or
this runs on yeah because if one of them
fails they should not have you should
have redundancy and you should not have
this this dependency that was created to
use old Tech to uh offer this product
because if you remove it
then you find that what ends up
happening is that other things are
[__] up in the thing right you can't
see tweets you can't see this you can't
do that all this stuff it's all [__]
connected and Elon doesn't know the
extent of how many things are actually
connected well speaking of things that
are [__] up let's continue with
with Tucker's little I actually haven't
seen this video I've watched part of it
so let's let's watch some more of it
if it'll [__] load God damn it man
when in doubt blame Elon Musk it is
Twitter I'm on Twitter doing this so
yeah it's crazy that's the one thing
that I think um is going to be
disappointing when Twitter fails Oh wait
we're gonna we're gonna have to find a
different [__] way to produce this
[__] well yeah I know it's the it'll
have to go on to Blue Sky and do it from
from Jack's new app well I've I've heard
that blue sky um it's kind of the same
way as the uh and I don't mean to cast
cast stones but occupy Democrats
platform what the [__] is that one
called oh tribal yeah where they where
they own your [__] content this guy
who's your content I haven't read that I
thought oh well or blue blue sky is
isn't like um okay well I don't know
read into it unless here we go let's
listen to the [__] here
amazingly as of tonight there aren't
many platforms left that allow Free
Speech Blaster man big one remaining in
the world the only one is Twitter where
we are now
Twitter has long served as the place
where our national conversation
incubates and develops Twitter is not a
partisan site everybody's allowed here
and we think that's a good thing they
didn't use it and yet for the most part
the news that you see analyzers comes
from media organizations that are
themselves thinly disguised propaganda
Outlets you see it on cable news you
talk about it on Twitter
the result may feel like a debate but
actually The Gatekeepers are still in
charge we think that's a bad system we
know exactly how it works
is there a mouse will be bringing a new
version of the show we've been doing for
the last six and a half years to Twitter
we've made some other things too which
we'll tell you about no you're not but
for now we're just grateful to be here
free speech is the main right that you
have without it you have no others see
you soon all right let me break this
down really quickly for you okay the
fact that he says uh Twitter is not
partisan okay
who has a bias towards white people
right he doesn't like anti-white
rhetoric especially when it comes to
Nazi Shooters right he's a big
conspiracy theorist he doesn't like the
fact that the media is portraying
Shooters as as white people he doesn't
like trans people right I mean even his
his uh his own child legally separated
themselves from Elon Musk went to the
courthouse changed their name and made
sure that they had nothing to do with
Elon anymore okay that was the LA
Courthouse uh here in LA
but you look at uh Tucker and being like
I'm gonna start a show on Twitter the
[__] you are so yesterday Tucker goes on
to he sent before he released this video
which by the way great day to release
the video because it [__] flopped it
right it was like squished after it was
after Trump uh was just found that he
was liable for sexually abusing Eugene
Carroll and was responsible for paying
five million dollars in Damages which by
the way she didn't even ask for she
never asked for the money but the jury
was like yo here we can't prove that he
sexually he he raped you but we do prove
that he's sexually abused you which
it'll be it'll be unlikely this yeah
I'm just going to chase this around
they're gonna appeal it whatever but the
fact that they get she was like I'm not
I'm just I want acknowledgment for the
fact that he committed this crime no I
don't want money
anyway so then you have him release this
within a span of three hours might I
like it was like noon here in L.A it was
like the Trump news dropped and then the
Twitter video dropped maybe like an hour
later and then George Santos dropped
like probably around like two o'clock or
something like that so or 2 30. so but
then like a three-hour window it was
like the biggest stories and the
smallest one that flopped was the Tucker
Carlson which is hilarious but the idea
that Tucker is going to start a show on
Twitter is hilarious because he's still
in contract with Fox News and the Contra
doesn't expire until January 2025. so
for them sued him yesterday too that was
the other side so that's that's what
happened the the series of events went
like this
he sent a letter from his attorney
saying hey they're Liars they're
committing fraud or the their fraud and
um and breach of contract because his
argument from the legal side is saying
well they promised me this and they said
I could do this and now they're just
holding me on the sidelines and they're
not letting me do anything they're
holding me to the contract which again
is still until January 2025 and then he
sends the video out on Twitter that was
what happened
and so what's funny is he can't do [__]
one there's no way to support having a
show outside of just live streaming like
we do on Twitter and two
he can't do anything until that contract
is resolved which is going to go in
court it's gonna be [__] appealed
this and appealed that they're gonna
fight it out they're gonna extend it as
long as they can he can't do [__] on
Twitter until that contract is resolved
because it would prove that it was a
breach of contract on his end but of
course he's saying well they breached
the contract first from Fox News so I'm
able to breach the contract now because
they did it first good luck go the other
thing luck the other thing too was the
cold water that Elon threw on it
yesterday oh yeah he was like almost
immediately he's like whoa whoa because
because I mean at first glance when they
seen this video the right Wingers went
nuts they're like oh yeah Yvonne and and
and Tucker are gonna [__] have a baby
oh they [__] love it the [__] the
Tucker and Elon porn was out in full
force they were come on they loved it
they loved it and then elon's like
so you know nothing is official yet we
haven't done anything
uh well do you think do you think do you
think Tucker jumped the shark on it I
think I think Tucker you know you know
what I mean right like like he like he
he he got out in front because he had
conversation with Elon elon's like yeah
yeah we'll do whatever you want man yeah
yeah you know how Elon is he'll say
whatever the [__] whatever the [__] he
needs to say in front of the people he
needs to say to me exactly feel powerful
and then and then and then and then when
he gets in a room and people with level
heads are like whoa you can't only give
Tucker Carlson an exclusive deal I mean
do that that's not freedom of speech
right here's Elon Street here's his
tweet yeah yeah
he says on this platform unlike the
one-way Street of broadcast people are
able to interact critique and refute
whatever is said and of course anything
misleading will get community notes
which Community notes becoming a joke
because they're becoming they're getting
abused right well because Elon keeps
talking about them that's why uh he says
I also want to be clear that we have not
signed a deal of any kind whatsoever
Tucker is subject to the same rules and
rewards of all content creators now
what's funny about this in the space
the guy who wears the [__] brick suit
at the Trump rallies within this space
Oh yeah these people
oh my God they're like the 4D chess
we're all playing and it's like dude
you're wearing a brick and go on here
it's not gonna go on here I just want to
point out this comment uh Dermot Fenster
Gabe just told us what's crazy about the
stack when Elon himself could not I bow
to the master I'm no master believe me
there are people that are way smarter
that do this stuff I just happen to have
years of experience of dealing with
idiots like Elon who say that you can do
certain things and not understanding the
actual code base behind it and this or
the work that would go into it yeah
exactly like this is something again
like even if even even if they signed a
contract and like we're gonna do it the
amount of development because just the
other day Elon did a video live using
Periscope code to his account and it
looked like [__] is that still let me
let me see if it's still I think it's
good I mean it might have been not a
deleted but either way what he did was
he tested it looked [__] all
pixelated because obviously like it was
rendering down which that's an easy fix
you can do whatever right if you want to
live stream use Periscope you can do
that it's going to look like [__] they
can fix it it'll look better however
there's a lot to go in there right like
what is the experience like when you go
in to find a broadcast are you saying
there's going to be a TV section the
closest thing to TV right now is when
you see news coverage live news coverage
uh Sports things like that but now you
have to determine who's getting
preference is in the people who pay the
check marks probably is there a high
hierarchy within the check mark kind of
order ranking yes of course there will
be
this all sounds really complicated Gabe
Sanchez well actually the the hierarchy
isn't too complicated in terms of how
you prioritize but what is going to be
complicated is how you build an
experience to have multiple things chat
within there because that's of course
something they want to copy from like
Tick Tock and Instagram live they have
to have with YouTube they gotta have
YouTube whatever it is right you have to
have playback you have to have different
components of this but again you have to
have think of it like
if it was like your your TV right and
you actually damn this guy tweets a lot
sorry just go to the you look at the
media tab yeah well he I I can't he must
have deleted it he might have deleted it
but the idea here is that they have to
create a whole experience when you go in
to be like oh great this is where I find
live broadcast this is where I find you
know previously broadcast right how are
you gonna find the Tucker show yeah you
have to go in and you'd have to search
right is it going to be a schedule
programming is it just gonna be ad hoc
when everything what about what about
the uh the preview because I can't
archive my previous broadcast right
right and there's just there on the TL
they just they just show as video right
so now you have to have something where
you're like okay well is it just video
is there an order to them is there uh
can I go back and see an index of all
the videos that I've had that are
specifically on a broadcast setting can
I go through and like I said before like
can I go through and find a schedule
that says between eight and nine PM you
would find the Tucker Carlson show right
it's on the Tucker TV channel or
whatever before after he posted that
titter picture he took oh it was way
after it was way after yeah I think he
might have deleted it I think so um but
it just goes to show you that like he
was testing it there and people like oh
you don't think he was testing for a
reason yeah I know exactly why he was
[__] testing it because he wants to
build a TV aspect he wants to use on
Periscope get the [__] out of here he
wants to he wants to build uh he wants
to build a TV component that would allow
for spaces to have video right so right
so basically like some sort of Zoom call
or the main speakers are able to talk I
mean the amount of [__] bandwidth
that your app has to have to support
multiple people broadcasting via video
in a [__] space when space is the
audio drops all the [__] time oh yeah
you have no way to pick up what people
said there you know transcription is
another thing accessibility there's all
of these problems that are that need to
be fixed before you could ever even
touch that [__] that's the beautiful
part about Tucker Carlson announcing
that he's going to be on Twitter is that
now he has to have the capability and he
doesn't have it yeah cracker Carlson
does not have the capability of
broadcasting the way he's going to want
to broadcast goose egg he's got just his
I got just as much capability as Tucker
Carlson does to broadcast because I can
tap into Periscope and push my signal
into Periscope and it will live stream
onto my Twitter that's it that's it
folks there's no archive there's no
nothing there's no engagement like you
can go over and comment right now on the
Twitter broadcast that we're
broadcasting on right now and I can't
see that [__] yeah I can't see it it
goes nowhere I would have to be on my
phone
to actually see that anyway in the
broadcast right in the broadcast and
right that's what we'd have to do so
this idea that [__] they're gonna
build Tucker Carlson this infrastructure
and that's what Ian said he's like Oh
They'll build it from the ground up I'm
like dude Tucker Carlson doesn't have
two years to be irrelevant man he
doesn't have that and that's the
beautiful part that's what I wanted to
even have the money to pay off the
goddamn interest on the 13 billion
dollar loan that he owns right he's got
a one and a half billion dollars he's
gonna build an entire
[__] out of here get the [__] out of
here you don't think that's gonna happen
it's not gonna happen but that's the
point that I want to make is that the
audience everyone out there that is that
is [__] upset that Tucker Carlson is
going to be broadcasting Twitter let me
tell you something even if he does it'll
be the exact same thing he did yesterday
where he will do a a produced piece and
he will post it on Twitter under his
blue check mark and that is it he's not
gonna broadcast and if he and if he does
broadcast live people are gonna laugh at
him people are gonna [__] hate it
even his supporters and he's not not
gonna get the other thing I want people
to understand is he's not going to get
the people the Boomers the Boomers that
were watching him on the 8 PM hour to go
get a cell phone to download the Twitter
app to figure out how to go to Tucker's
page to [__] watch the broadcast that
night of Tucker Carlson on Twitter even
if he is live streaming get the [__] out
of here do you know how many other lift
it's going to be to get Twitter and
Periscope to uh to uh Ott which is like
the YouTube app that you have because a
lot of people watch us on the YouTube
app on their TV do you know how [__]
much of a heavy lift it is to get there
oh yeah I mean you have to I mean for
people who don't know like Ott is a
direct stream from one source to another
source so if you're like we wanna like
we did it with Midas Touch when we did
the Jan 6 coverage we had a direct feed
from Reuters from from their you know uh
their own control room directly into
YouTube right straight line unfettered
versus like we were doing it if we were
and we didn't even use the
Ott feed we use the YouTube feed because
we figured we could count on the YouTube
feed right better because it was easier
to do inside of a browser we needed less
bandwidth to find the whole idea that
they're like oh we're gonna have people
that are set up remotely to do a control
room and actually you feel like we're
going to camera One camera two camera
three we're gonna play this media we're
gonna play this thing [__] no that's not
at all gonna happen and on top of that
is the idea that that that Elon Musk
thinks he can use old code again old
code 2015 code that hasn't been touched
and really just maintain so it doesn't
break the [__] app which it kind of
already has in in some ways
um is use that to fix it right and it
and it's just the idea that
really it comes back to the idea that I
was saying before which is like people
do not have attention spans that are
longer than a couple minutes because
most videos on Twitter support two
minutes and 20 seconds most people
unless you pay for Twitter blue you get
two minutes and 20 seconds and most
Clips don't need to be longer than that
because people just cut and splice how
they want the like moments to be
because they know that people are on
their feed and I've got one tweet a
second tweet I got a text message it's
all [__] short attention spans and no
one is gonna stay around for a [__]
hour-long coverage I'm sure there might
be people on Twitter right now that
watch our show but I guarantee that very
many people are not consistent and they
are not retaining they're going over to
retention the retention if we look at
this the data like I'm sure the
retention goes well that's great because
Periscope doesn't have a lot of data
speaking of attention spans I got I'm
gonna move on to another story because
um I I believe we need to show the clip
of Grandpa poopypants's response from
his guilty verdict yesterday this is
this is [__] hilarious man oh my God
so we have we have given him and Liz
Harrington a lot of pointers and he
totally missed it here like he's been
doing these scripted versions but
yesterday they didn't they didn't even
have a script ready for the guilty
verdict and it is clear from this video
that they didn't have the ability I'm
surprised for the amount of like I'm the
victim I'm the victim he was priming
everyone to say you would think yeah he
would be like look they're gonna say
just like set it up be like I'm innocent
this is a Witch Hunt it's all a hoax I
didn't know I don't know that woman at
all like all this [__] but he
clearly he's clearly doing yourself the
cup I got a comment here I want to take
care of some business here Karen asked
is there butt deodorant sponsor yet no
but I am in contact we are doing emails
back and forth to get the butt deodorant
sponsor so so we may be talking more and
more
I would willing to I'd be willing to
stick on my butt would you a deodorant
stick all right okay
speaking of uh living
deodorant sticks here's one right here
let's see what he had to say about how
they they they they they they they they
made me guilty let's listen a trump
hating Clinton appointed judge who went
out of his way to make sure that the
result
of this trial was as negative as it
could possibly be
speaking to and in control of a jury
from an anti-trump area oh which is
probably the worst place in the United
States for me to get a fair trial okay
so here's the thing here's the thing
this dude lived in Manhattan his entire
life up until a couple years ago all the
cases that are going to be leveled
against him are where he lived when he
did these crimes what the [__] doesn't
that what but also the idea he's like he
was like he did as much as he could to
make this a bad result he he said show
up or shut up right stop bitching right
stop complaining from your golf course
and [__] Ireland or wherever you were
like if you want to cry like a little
[__] ass [__] get on a plane come to
Manhattan and sit your ass in the
courtroom and say what you have to say
to defend yourself to say that you don't
know the woman this is a lie so shut the
[__] up or show up right imagine what's
happening Regina makes a good point I
know I did notice purple making minces I
think he's he's switching up his
strategy Regina I'm glad you caught that
because I'm telling you I'm telling you
this this is not this is not the advice
that we would give uh Liz for these
videos is dude I mean it goes to show
you the you know there is I don't know
if he's trying to cross go across the
aisle or try to be like the red ties too
much we gotta go purpose maybe maybe
well let's let's continue to listen to
this whiny little [__] because it's
it's glorious little listen
we'll be appealing this decision it's a
disgrace I don't even know who this
woman is
can you scroll back look at his face
look at his face this one
right when he says I don't know who this
woman is
right there that one right there yeah
play it
I have no idea who she no go go back go
back go back a little bit further he
repeats it he repeats it well of course
he does I don't even know who this woman
is look at that face no idea
where she came from this is another scam
it's a political Witch Hunt and somehow
you're gonna have to fight this stuff we
cannot do it
go into this event we what's this we
[__] what's this wee [__] he keeps it
[__] you grabbed her by the [__] you
defamed her you did it you did it you
did it know what we we didn't tell you
to go up on stage and say [__] Eugene
Carroll I wouldn't rape her she's ugly
and I don't rape ugly women wow he
wouldn't go on stage and say about uh
The Other Woman I'm blinking her name
right now he was like oh she's totally
not my type I wouldn't do that yeah yeah
yeah leads and also you know nobody not
we okay stop saying [__] we nobody
include us you were the one under a
deposition said oh I wouldn't find you
attractive either right and and us we
understand decision you pointed to the
picture and said that's my wife pointing
at a picture of e Gene Carroll at that
time period where you grabbed her by the
[__] years later bragging about it to
Billy Bush on a bus and let me tell you
something if people don't know this that
is the this single time that Donald
Trump got caught on a hot mic saying
that he has said that time and time and
time again and it's clear in his
deposition because we didn't say in your
deposition that well of course men have
been doing it for millions of years of
course Stars can grab people by the
[__] it's been happening forever it's
just just something that happens like
you said that during your deposition you
not we don't drag us into this I mean
yeah the idea that looks like when I did
the face time of him he's like we will
fight them and it's like stop [__]
saying we man I am not involved in this
this is a you problem you said those
things you committed those crimes stop
trying to say that I am included in this
group this this uh this we this us it's
not no no no no it's a you solo only
right not any of us did it let's listen
let's listen to uh Han Solo here oh my
God this is disgraceful you have
somebody running for office here's where
he's getting off script and lied about
it she totally lied about it by Democrat
operatives like just about the biggest
one there is okay so this is another
talking point so he doesn't say George
Soros here and the reason why is because
they're getting a new Democratic
operatives name in their mouth and they
said it in the space yesterday and they
had to have the memo go out to all these
[__] Chuckles
that's right better paid paid operatives
to push this narrative that the name
You're Gonna Hear folks let me tell you
the name the name is Reed Hoffman they
were saying it yesterday in spaces
that's who Donald Trump is saying saying
here Donald Trump doesn't want to say it
in this video because Reed Hoffman is
the billionaire that Donald Trump wants
to be reedoffman has a shitload of
[__] money he's football [__] Rich
Oh yes any woman buried Donald Trump and
defamation lawsuits if he tries that
[__] so so that's why Donald Trump says
you know who he is and then all his
little [__] minions go out into
Twitter spaces and they type it on
Twitter and social media that it's Reid
Hoffman but that's who they're talking
about I guaran damned to you within the
next six months we're gonna hear that
name over and over it's gonna be Hunter
Minds laptop and Reed Hoffman that's
what we're gonna hear and I think what
they're doing here again with the
readoff and stuff
is that they know George Soros is like I
mean he's like a thousand years old
right yeah he's really old again I think
he's gonna be alive anymore so they're
gonna pick the new one you know what I
mean the idea I mean yes to your point
earlier is
it would be I mean I don't know I kind
of would I kind of was hoping that he
would say Reed Hoffman's name after
after leaving a nation trial and get in
charge five million dollars it was
really rich for someone else you [__]
idiot he's defaming he's defaming Eugene
Carroll in this [__] clip right like
why you just got you're gonna just bear
which is why which is interesting
because like Hoffman's connection with
people like Peter Thiel right right and
like the idea that these are the people
Elon Musk these are all right people
work together they're all in the same
space man if anyone knows [__] Reed
Hoffman LinkedIn the PayPal Mafia other
companies
they're all [__] connected
that's what they're called tell the
audience what paper what the paper so
the PayPal Mafia are people like Reed
Hoffman Peter Thiel Elon Musk uh I'm uh
Jason kalikanis I think is another one
on there I'm trying to remember there's
there's a group of them but basically
it's all of these people who were
involved in starting PayPal and they
aren't that [__] Rich right and which
eBay eventually bought PayPal on that
right so that's what made them super
rich and really eBay is nothing PayPal
is everything now yeah I mean it's the
whole once you own the the the
payment platform you own that [__] right
and so that is where they all got their
money then they took that money and they
started other companies right and Reid
Hoffman went on and you started LinkedIn
and some other [__] and they all have
[__] billions so the idea that Trump
wants to go obviously you know smartly
for him to not defame another person's
name and let the internet just kind of
go for it right it's [__] hilarious
because they've now they've now gone
from an old rich white guy right because
again they like this Narrative of old
rich men like like Biden uh uh George
Soros they're lazy they're working from
a basement yet at the same time there
are these puppeteers who are very you
know maliciously and intently moving the
strings and the pieces to say do this do
that but at the same time they want to
say that these are old decrepit sleepy
people you know it's like witches
they're either masterminds evil
masterminds or they're like geriatric
[__] people in a home which is it
right well I don't I don't know Reed
Hoffman I don't know him I mean I hope I
read if you're sending out Hoffman
checks like this because Soros checks
are not showing up man the Soros checks
are just not showing up so if you got
Hoffman checks send those [__]
my way I'll give you my address just DM
me but I don't know reedoffman but the
fact is is that they're pivoting to
someone who is a big player in Silicon
Valley and that and that's that that's
the craziest part is they're pivoting
from George Soros who's who's kind of
this this you know kind of odd figure
right in inside of and it gives a lot of
political money into a lot of democratic
causes just like a lot of [__] Rich
Republicans like Harlan Hitler who has a
assigned copy of mine comp gives a
shitload of money to buy Supreme Court
Justices get the [__] out of here with
that [__] and all billionaires are all
political and they use their money to
spend politically to make it to where
they get the [__] laws and the
policies that their billionaire asses
benefit from it's how it works but Reed
Hoffman Roderick says here read Auburn
will bring hot sauce and eat him up like
a catfish oh my God Donald Trump is way
out in front of his skis when he's
[__] with Reed Hoffman that's how I
see it you do not he is here here's the
thing
you go after Reed Hoffman again it's all
[__] connect you got Elon Musk is
running Twitter and everyone's [__]
for that guy you got Peter Thiel who is
a big financier into the Maga Republican
movement so it's like probably best not
to directly name the person well I mean
it's just it's honestly it's astounding
that the guy keeps [__] saying [__]
but I mean like we've talked about
[__] go for it man keep saying this
[__] yeah let's do it well let's let's
finish let's finish Grandpa's little
rant here
and she said that wasn't true they found
that she lied about it and the judge
wasn't even I guess letting it be put in
oh my God what the [__] is going on damn
it's a shame and it's a disgrace to our
country to our country what what the
[__] does this have to stop doing the
country thing this ain't got nothing to
do with the country man you you are in a
department store you thought you're a
star and for millions of years Stars can
grab women wherever they want however
they want whenever they want even in the
dressing room and you did it she [__]
went out told her [__] friends at the
time oh my God I was in the dress room
damn drunk grabbed me and that's what
happened and then she [__] came out
and said her truth made the world know
her truths so the world knew what truth
was and then you defamed her you
[__] and by defaming her that
set off the [__] lawsuit and you
aren't you are the bonehead who did this
to yourself don't bring the country into
it don't bring the Wii [__] into it it
is is a you problem just like the you
problem you got at the Manhattan DA's
office with the 34 felony counts for
[__] defrauding the state of New York
by by by banging up your [__] books
and cooking your books [__] you go to
hell this ain't a wee thing this is a
you problem Grandpa change your diaper
Move Along Move Along would you please
all right well the address the best part
about this
is um this sets The Narrative and
yesterday oh my God I threw flames in
that Twitter space I did I threw Flames
this morning too when I go in there like
the whole room just ignites like I raise
the temperature I mean on purpose I'm
like look here [__] and I just
it goes from like simmering hot you know
like right before you're gonna crack an
egg and Fry the egg to like boiling hot
like that's what I want I want the
[__] grease popping over you know
when it hits you and you [__] just
burn in your face when you're cooking
that's what I want I want to raise the
temperature so yesterday I went in and
uh I think Jim was there I don't
remember who it was I pissed off kim.com
today too he called me a disrupter which
when kim.com calls you to disrupter I'm
I'm proud of that but uh yesterday
yesterday I was like
um you [__] boneheads keep seeing
liable but he's guilty and they're like
oh no you can't say that that's
defamation I'm like you're stupid you
stupid bastards don't understand before
you woke up this morning everyone was
waiting to see if Donald Trump was
guilty you stupid [__] the American
people don't distinguish the difference
between libel and guilt it's guilt guilt
guilt guilt and I was asked the question
what do you think is a result of today's
verdict and I said actually I think I
think the good part about today's
verdict more than anything more than e
Gene carer gets her truth um right
she'll probably never receive the money
the truth is most important to her that
the world knows now that hey the
[__] the [__] did what
he did he said what he said we know what
he did and he defamed her but the most
important thing for our country and the
politics and The Narrative of our
country is that the word guilt and the
word Donald Trump are starting to appear
in sentences right as news and that's
the most important part is because
there's going to be a lot of that those
sentences of trump and guilt Trump and
guilt Trump and guilt over the next
three or four years and this country is
going to have to get used to that [__]
especially the people who are really in
their feels about it because he's a
[__] criminal and they don't want him
to be they want him to be the president
I'm gonna [__] them so
um okay so let's speaking of current
Turtles speaking of criminals your buddy
your buddy turned himself in this
morning
did you
did you text him while he was turning
himself in you know I let's see uh I
texted him last night but I remembered
that he blocked me so my messages don't
get through this isn't a joke folks
literally gave Sanchez yeah you know
what I'll show you on the screen
he literally texts George Santos last
night all right so here's uh over Darren
is yeah uh I think the reflection yeah
the reflection you can't see it anyway
anyways so I have these text messages
and I went back and forth and one of the
things I said back in March and I said
this is after after a plea deal had been
announced I said any comment on
accepting a deal with problems that's
for Brazil right yeah in Brazil uh
saying in December 2022 that you did not
commit a crime in Brazil to which he
responded surprisingly no deal has been
made this news is not factual and is
absolutely contrarian I don't think he
meant that uh I think what he meant to
say he's absolutely contrary to to what
my attorney maybe maybe it's an auto
correct maybe it's an autocorrect
problem I'd go back to the drawing board
and pick another form of smearing me oh
okay got it so then I said just to
clarify you said uh so I said just to
clarify you stand by your statement
quote I am not a criminal here not here
or in Brazil or any jurisdiction in the
world absolutely not that didn't happen
end quote then on April 25th I message
him back again after it was announced in
Brazil that they had reached an
agreement as to what the deal was which
was he would agree to confess formally
and he would pay compensation to the
victim which I think is like thirteen
hundred dollars or something and so I I
I I I I messaged him back and I said
Roderick here uh wait a second Roderick
on YouTube says Gabe got him arrested
yay I don't I don't know if that's
exactly the case but you did frustrate
him I did I I would I I did play a part
to some things that happened that I
uncovered but uh so so then on March
25th I said Santos now that a statement
a settlement has been reached with
Brazilian prosecutors would you like to
correct your previous statement or are
you still denying any criminal activity
and I said in case you forgot
your previous statement was I'm not a
criminal here not here in Brazil or any
jurisdiction in the world absolutely not
that didn't happen and I said and since
you have now agreed to formally confess
to the crime and pay compensation to the
victim when and where will that take
place and he goes who is this I don't
have this number saved and then I said
I'm an independent journalist and I
asked him what you said on this date and
he goes I don't speak to unnamed people
so then I told him that my name was Phil
Corbell because I said if you're making
a [__] name I'm making a [__] name
and then I said Mr Sanchez would you
like to comment or change your previous
statement regarding your criminal
activity in Brazil and then I email and
then I message him
yesterday and I said Mr Santos and a
comment on being charged by the doj in a
federal probe didn't go through so then
I said [__] George Santos and I called
him I called him from an announce I'll
I'll admit to this I called him from an
anonymous number and George Santos
picked up on the first [__] room what
did he say and he goes hello who is this
and I go George I didn't even call him
Santos representative
George you don't get a title [__] I was
like George and he goes who is this and
I go George are you there George and he
goes who who's calling me who is this
and I said hi George I'm calling to get
a statement about your recent charge
click hey now that's what happened so
then so then what happened was I was
like oh what was this what time was this
last night this was yesterday yeah what
time Eastern Eastern time don't give me
your [__] Pacific time I want to know
when it was uh
3 32 p.m Pacific so 660 6 32 so so
Santos was eating dinner possibly yeah
he was probably eating dinner but
thinking about oh what his plans were
tomorrow right well I mean he was he was
definitely planning to self surrender
right right so so then what happened was
I called him again
rang rang rang went to voicemail called
him again rang rang rang voicemail call
him again rang rang went to voicemail
call him again rang rang rang went to
voicemail I kept [__] calling that
[__] for two hours I was like I think I
called him 12 times
never picked back up went to voicemail
called him again went to voicemail
called him again went to voicemail God
damn and then and they were only
ghosting you and then I got to a point
where I was walking my dogs and I was
out in the neighborhood and I was like
hey I haven't called George Santos in a
while I should call him back uh Phil
Corbell like that but
c-o-r-b-e-l-l that's how I that's how I
spelled it then and then I am I'm on my
walk with my dogs and I call them again
and I know oh [__] it went straight to
voicemail and I was like oh I need to
make sure that I didn't I was not
calling from my number
to check because now that he had me
blocked on my personal number
he uh he had me blocked so go straight
to voicemail
so then I was like oh I should come from
Anonymous again so I'd call him from
Anonymous again and it went straight to
voicemail so I am taking credit for the
fact that I annoyed George Santos so
[__] much yesterday by my calling my
investment calling to get a quote from
George Santos on his federal charges
that he turned his phone off and his
phones you know it stayed off because I
tried it again even later in the night
it went straight to voicemail ah dude it
clearly is off because he surrendered
himself to the courthouse or you know
and is now uh under under you know
Federal custody whatever so that is what
I did most recently
um star six seven is a [__] and
if you answer an unknown number that's
on you that's right that's on you so
that person started star six seven
before the night yeah that's what we do
star six seven before the number and
it'll go up as Anonymous so the idea
that [__] George Santos first ring
picks up hello who is this
wait who's calling he was probably he
probably thought it was like um The New
York Times or some [__] probably he was
hoping that he was hoping that somebody
was going to be like look George I've
got these documents that can get you out
immunity that's what it is yep yep I'm
expecting a call from some
asset in a place called
Russia
three of these charges could be here's
here's uh um representative Pete Aguilar
on the George Santos Kevin McCarthy
thing uh he said this this morning let's
see let's see I'm sure he's nice about
it let's find out
Kevin McCarthy owns George Santos Lock
Stock
if George Santos wasn't seated what
would the math have been for speaker
McCarthy he would have had to flip
another Vote or get two people to vote
present I mean this is he he owns George
Santos that's the only reason why he was
seated and this is the only reason why
they're gonna they're gonna slow walk
the ethics investigation because they
don't want they don't want George Santos
to leave and then wasn't he arraigned
isn't he being arraigned right like at
1pm well I I'm not sure at the time so
he turned himself in this morning and
there's a lot of processing that happens
um before you're arraigned but the
magistrate has to be available for you
to be arraigned so the Manchester I saw
something online that said he was going
to be around it could be scheduled PM
yeah it could be scheduled it could be
scheduled for the magistrate to iranum
at 1 pm and the arraignment probably
won't take longer than now probably
probably
maybe 20 minutes but he's gonna have
some processing afterwards as well
because there's processing before your
arraignment processing after because
he's going to be under indictment yeah
it means they're going to release him of
his own recognance uh so he'll leave the
courthouse
today after his arraignment after he's
done being processed um here is Kevin
McCarthy this is during a oh well I
thought this had to do with George
Santos no that's not okay hold on this
is some [__] shade what hold on who's
Throwing Shade on who click click that
link
when you say it like that I really don't
try I mean usually when you send me
click that link just click the link man
just click the link click the link click
the link okay so what is this
so that's uh Hannah Hannah Spengler and
uh she's a she's the chief of staff to
uh representative uh Don Davis of the
DNC and she says miss our neighbor
already
poor guy
so sad oh man GOP Representative Steve
Womack he's not gonna get his um his
newspaper today oh man Representative
Steve Womack of Arkansas told reporters
on Capitol Hill on today that Santo
should resign from Congress he's not
gonna [__] resign no well he just
announced his rerun he already announced
his campaign run and that's the reason
why I didn't announce that before he got
indicted right I also have uh I also
have a statement here from the U.S
attorney it says the uh it's an end I'm
reading yeah is it a tweet it's not a
tweet it's just from I mean I'll send
you the link yeah send me a link and
then put it up on the screen and why
we're going here
um this is uh this is uh NBC news
reporting this I guess
I see here
did I lose you no no no oh okay all
right so I was getting I'm getting I'm
getting texts about Santos real time
right now so not from Santos but about
Santos I've got multiple multiple people
that are texting me to do [__] on on
Santos do a parody do a what was that
don't worry what was that is definitely
coming on this [__] again so is
this
um U.S attorney peace it says taking
together the allegations in the
indictment charge Santos with relying on
repeated dishonesty and deception to
send to the halls of Congress and enrich
himself he said who is the United States
Attorney he used political contributions
uh to lying his pockets unlawfully
applied for unemployment benefits that
should have gone to New Yorkers who lost
their jobs during the pandemic and liked
in the House of Representatives do we
know the exact lies that he's telling
the house to represent us because I know
there was uh there was a hubbub about
how he he was hiring another Finance
accountant and stuff and right so that
the lies on his disclosures is that the
lines that they're it could be that one
but it also could be the one so let me
read that again apply it to unemployment
benefits okay yeah yeah that was during
covid uh he will continue aggressively
without corruption
um and then the covet the unemployment
coveted payments must be the um the um
um What charges would that be those are
ones that he got during 2020 and I think
they were for his business if I remember
correctly oh um so he's got PPP press
yeah so there's there's PPP loan stuff I
remember I gotta read through the
indictment again so I'll tell you and
during 2020
um so I worked for a company a friend of
mine who who got PPP money and when he
was looking to it and I was looking to
it because I owned a couple businesses
um he was like don't do it don't do it
do this a [__] trap he's like I
shouldn't have done it he said the only
reason why I did it is to give you guys
your P what was uh for you guys he said
but it's a [__] trap he said so many
people are gonna there's so much abuse
that can happen on this and they're
they're gonna [__] federally indict
every single person who does this wrong
and apparently George Santos did it
wrong because it was uh it was 13 counts
right of wire fraud unlawful monetary
transactions one count of public funds
is that the one one yeah the public
funds that's probably the PPP money yeah
um so there's a whole dude it's a whole
thing man like this oh okay George
Sanchez is currently demanding stricter
work restrictions for Medicaid
beneficiaries he's accused of
fraudulently collecting unemployment
benefits while earning 120 000 salary
that was a [__] what an answer it
says it says an application devolder
Santos falsely claimed to have been
unemployed since the week of March 2022
2020 beginning on about June 19 2020 and
continuing through about April 15 2021
devolder Santo certified his continuing
eligibility for unemployment benefits on
a weekly basis in which each case he
falsely testifying uh enter Alia I don't
know that legal term uh that he was
unemployed available to take on New York
and eligible for benefits in truth and
in fact however beginning on or around
February 3rd 2020 and continuing oh wow
so even before he [__] applied for it
February 3rd even before the [__]
pandemic
on or about February 3rd 2020 and
continuing through on or about April 15
2021 the boulder Santos was a regional
director and investment firm one which
is one of the company that they that
they indicated uh during that period
with the exception of on or uh or about
and between July 5th 2020 and August
30th 2020 devolder Santos received
regular deposits into his personal bank
accounts as part of his Regional
director salary of approximately 100
000 so he was employed and collecting
unemployment he also yeah so he
defrauded the government of nearly
twenty five thousand dollars in
unemployment benefits and then then got
into Congress and immediately tried to
slash those benefits records that's
probably part of the wire fraud too
because it would be direct deposits um
here is here's the first page of the
indictment I want to go back to this
because I think this is [__]
hilarious oh yeah and really honestly I
think we should be uh pushing to pass
legislation to get emojis uh as part of
um that we can put on federal
indictments just because of this here
because it says United States of America
against George Anthony devolder Santos
otherwise known as George Santos also
known as guitar ravage also known as
yeah I just I want the Emoji I want the
Emoji like
George Santos
one of those things look honestly your
best your guess is as good as mine right
like the idea that like it it could be
George Anthony to Boulder George Anthony
devolder Santos George devolder George
De volder Santos George Santos guitar
ravage what was the other one he had
another name in there it was a it was it
was the Ukrainian one that he went by
that he said my grandparents fled the
Holocaust right oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
but it was the Jewish one because he
said Jewish last names will get Jewish
people to donate more money
so um so more news here on uh the Cheeto
desk you and honor uh it is being it
looks like more and more people because
of the CNN town hall because CNN's not
going to back away from this which
honestly if CNN had any [__] guts
they wouldn't back away this they'd lean
into this [__] yeah um they would lean
way into this do we know who's uh who's
the person that is going to be like yeah
um it is
um shirt name is God damn it
um it was on that video like why not put
[__] Anderson Cooper if you're gonna
put him on you put the person who
actually knows how to challenge knows
how to hold people accountable right
right I don't I don't um
I don't know who she is but the the the
talk is is that Trump might back out of
this
um oh that would be [__] hilarious
because he released a video this morning
the reason why the reason why oh pull
that video
um the reason why the talk is is he
wants to do it but I think his campaign
and his allies are saying don't [__]
do it man you're gonna destroy you're
you he doesn't you do not want this
idiot in front of cameras where the
majority of the American people can see
him talking about this case holy [__]
if they ask Caitlin Caitlyn Collins is
is what people are saying Oh okay that's
the I I don't watch [__] CNN at all
yeah I mean I don't know I mean I watch
I watched the clips when it's newsworthy
but that that's it I don't [__] sit
and watch that [__]
um I very rarely listen to MSNBC every
once while usually on Mondays
um I'll I'll listen to Morning Joe but
it's very rare that I even listen to
that
um because it's sometimes it's [__]
garbage but here let me find let me find
the um the trailer that they had and if
you find the video then we'll play the
two together because he's bragging about
it in this video is that what you're
saying he's excited yeah he's like hey
boxing he also he uh CNN he shits on CNN
and says they're desperate to take the
the hall
so he shits on him oh yeah absolutely
well and the reason why he's doing that
is because he's trying to you know both
sides of the fence this [__] because
it's likely that if if uh Caitlyn has
any kind of wherewithal as far as an
interviewer she's really going to press
him on this issue make him look like if
I had the opportunity if anyone at Fox
News or CNN sorry I keep I mean that's
what they are right they're foxing is
like uh if at this point if anyone had
the decency to actually do this then
they would they would have the the
[__] balls look if I'm gonna go out
like I'm gonna be fired from a [__]
news station it would be because I asked
the right questions right I asked the
actual hard-hitting questions I wouldn't
[__] play Kate oh we gotta we got a
sugar cutter we gotta give a softball
one we gotta play nice the guy [__]
uh has broken the law on multiple
occasions he's under investigation he
has now been proven
that he is legally in the court of law
sexually abused e Gene Carroll he uh he
he's under investigation in Atlanta or
in a in in Fulton County uh Jack Smith
when it comes to Mar-A-Lago the
documents Jan six
um you know uh Leticia James uh you've
got
um
just saying he's [__] he's [__] I
mean
20 million ways to Sunday right Any
Which Way but Loose yeah it's honestly
like the guy is not in a great position
on any and any stance and it would be it
would be
awful terrible and shitty if somebody
who was moderating this said you know
what I'm not going to ask any of these
things well I mean I I would imagine
that Donald Trump has tried to make an
agreement on what can and cannot be
talked about
um yeah that's what I would do [__] that
just oh yeah we agreed we agreed you
signed off on these questions and then I
would immediately be like all right so
I'll probably go with the first three to
like so say all those questions no I
would just talk these questions anyway
let's let's talk about the rape huh
let's talk about it let's talk about how
you're guilty [__] so here's the promo
that was released I think last week of
this uh Town Hall they're calling it
um someone say it's uh like a a Nazi
rally type thing but let's let's let's
see what uh CNN frames it up as former
president Donald Trump takes questions
live from CNN's Caitlyn Collins and New
Hampshire GOP Primary voters their
issues their concerns their votes a CNN
Republican Presidential Town Hall May
10th at 90s so there it is there's the
original promo so and they they painted
it in a good light but you're saying the
this video that he's doing he kind of
shits on him is what you're saying oh
yeah he should sound him pretty big okay
and then goes see me there at 8 pm
they suck and it's a horrible network
but I'll be on it let's listen to what
[__] grandpa says I'll be doing CNN
tonight live from the great state of New
Hampshire because
CNN is rightfully desperate to get those
fantastic
it's like none other oh God damn
they made me a deal I couldn't refuse
could be the beginning of a new and
vibrant CNN with no more fake news or it
could be a total disaster yeah disaster
tonight at eight o'clock oh it's gonna
be a [__] [__] show man she doesn't
even have to impress him hard listen
they're they're in this in this
environment right in the in the in what
the truths that we live in right now
there's not a lot of softballs you can
throw this guy what softball I mean what
are you gonna say like do you still like
ketchup I mean you're throwing it all I
mean do you still like it do you still
eat ketchup on your cheese you know do
you still have small hands right you
still have a tiny baby penis is is it
still a problem in terms of penetration
that no one can feel it do you still
feel insecure about the fact that you
weren't successful in your attempted
coup of the government on January 6th uh
are you still someone who has 3 AM
riddle Adderall driven tweets or or
truth social posts do you feel do you
still wear [__] diapers uh everywhere
you go uh I mean like these are all the
these are the questions that I would ask
uh on top of the ones about
uh uh do you admit to two attempts
correctly assaulting 26 different women
right
um you know it's just it's I mean it
goes on and on and on and these
Republicans are going to defend these
criminals and just like Elise stephanic
here here's a clip uh out with George
Santos we're back to the George Santos
but we're really just on the whole
Republicans or criminals thing because
that's the theme Here is there a bunch
of [__] criminals let's listen let's
listen to this gaslighter talk about the
the man she helped get elected because
that's the truth she helped George
Santos get elected let's listen this
legal process is going to play itself
out unfortunately this is not the first
time a member of Congress from either
party has been indicted there are a set
of rules and as the majority leader
stated he voluntarily had stepped down
from his committees uh we are committed
to making sure that we root out any
fraud when it comes to Unemployment uh
pandemic assistance and we're working to
have uh support from our conference and
it's good policy and we urge the
Democrats to vote in support of it
they just don't know they lose the plot
line too much at least stefanik is so I
mean she's so deep in the George Santos
like [__] storms that's going on she she
went there I don't know how many times
she went there to help him get elected
but she went there a lot oh yeah I mean
she's the you have to remember how much
how how invested she is personally her
own political clout is is tied to George
Santos and the outcome that happens here
because the idea that she's like oh well
let let us not forget that people on
both sides of the aisle have been
indicted before on federal charges yeah
I'm not saying that's not true right
people are people and they're going to
be criminals depending on where they are
on the aisle and some people remain in
Congress or in the Senate and some don't
there just happens to be a lot of people
on the right who are groomers pedophiles
sexual predators or just outright
[__] Federal criminals right it just
happens it happens speaking speaking of
more people reacting I I think I should
just do a lightning round because
there's a lot of Clips I want to show so
let's do a quick writing around this is
Mike Pence responding
um to Donald Trump's uh guilty uh
verdict in the E Gene Carroll
deformation and sexual abuser trial
where he was convicted I don't give a
[__] what you say libel libel no
whatever he's guilty [__] right here we
go in my four and a half years serving
alongside the president I I never heard
or witnessed
behavior of that nature you couldn't
you're not allowed to be in a room with
women why how the [__] could Mike Pence
well we'll well what we do know he is
allowed to be in the room with women as
long as he's in the room with mother
which is his wife which is [__] weird
right well but that's what I'm saying is
I mean how would he know if he wouldn't
Mother wasn't there okay you want to
hear another bone-headed one here's
another bonehead or it's not bone end of
the week but we got another one here we
go uh as we have heard today there are
numerous concerns related to so-called
environmental social and governance
policies being uh indoctrinated into
accounts by woke asset managers today's
hearing will help us better understand
what Congress can do to ensure that
activist stakeholders will not be
encouraged woke
corporate activism as we have seen
recently with Anheuser-Busch Disney and
even Nike because as we all know around
here when you go woke you go broke so I
I love I love when she's like okay I
want you to get as many big words that
doesn't sound like I know because I
don't know to put him in a speech and to
put in his speech that is against
freedom of speech where companies get to
do whatever they want when they're
marketing they can Market to an audience
they can use an influencer rather
they're a right-wing 2A bro by the way
Bud Light I don't know if you guys know
this Bud Light pays right wing gun
activists to put their products in their
Instagram videos they do it they do it
just like they paid Dylan Mulvaney to
put it in her videos but anyways this
idea that they don't have freedom of
speech to work in the freedom in the
free market this is such fascism but she
didn't even know that because she's
trying to get through this statement and
then she loves the n-words go whoa go
broke baby yeah she's like I gotta put
in that little catchphrase there and
it's like God damn there's no one no one
that's listening to me is gonna [__]
understand what I'm saying every every
day I'm like man is there anyone that's
dumber than Lauren bobert and usually
there's a republican like margiela green
or someone else that proves that he's
not the only one wait wait wait I may
found one oh I found me one here I found
one here I want to show this clip too
this is Jim Comer and with all these
[__] idiots surrounding him at his
little press conference where he's gonna
take down Biden this is the evidence
that they have that Joe Biden isn't a
criminal because they have no evidence
let's listen but are you going to be
able to prove the central pieces that
President Biden was directly involved
with corruption without getting fake
records for either President Biden James
Biden Hunter Biden showing the transfer
of money or the payments of expenses
that President Biden should picked up
himself and secondly on the FBI
informant file are you going to be able
to provide us any more information today
on that such as which country pertains
to
um and is there any evidence that
President Biden this offshore bank
accounts
okay so the question is what the [__]
does this have to do with President
Biden right that's the basic question do
you have proof that right Joe Biden
President Joe Biden point was the person
who said hey give me this money or was
somehow involved in transferring money
between certain parties right so let's
listen to the answer because I'm sure
it's compelling let's let's listen to
all the evidence that that Jim Comey
speaks into the microphone here well
first of all with respect to to
President Biden I don't think anyone in
America who's watching C-SPAN or any
other network that's covering this would
think that it's just a coincidence that
nine Biden family members who have
received money so uh for this influence
peddling scheme I mean what as as
representative Jordan and the other
speakers that what business is there the
media has always said two things first
of all media said many in the media have
said that no transactions happened while
Joe Biden was vice president we've
proven that wrong Joe Biden said during
2020 that his family never took any
money from China today we've proven that
wrong and you have it in your memorandum
the the bank
uh transfers
so we believe that the president has
been involved in this from the very
beginning it doesn't matter what you
believe [__] it doesn't matter what you
believe it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter just like just like it doesn't
matter Donald Trump believes that he's
being he's it's a Witch Hunt get the
[__] out of here man I I love listen if
if you're not if you're not paying
attention to the uh the the press
conference this morning I listened to
most of it I didn't watch it I listened
while I was working out and I had to
respond in this Twitter space that's why
I listened to it I listen to every
single garbage thing they were saying
all the transactions that they found on
the treasury website literally there is
a clip there is a a point in this
broadcast or this press conference where
Jim Comer is asked where did you find
the evidence that you have today he
literally says well it's on the internet
like
what
Whoa man like on Facebook
what the internet is well that's a good
question is this remember he's the same
guy he's the same guy when asked by Jake
Jake Tapper he said hey should Donald
Trump also uh
face the same responsibility or
consequence if documents are found just
like you're you're saying that Joe Biden
should for documents that were found in
his garage and he goes no no I think
they're totally different they're not
the same at all well Q Anon is a hell of
a drug man she went on and I might tell
you something Jim Comer is a [__]
Cuban honor he is he is full on Q Anon
and Q anon's a hell drug it's it's a q
Anon World we're just living it there's
a lot of ways to say this right we're at
the intersection of WrestleMania real
life there's a lot of ways of saying
this but we're [__] out of time God
damn we're out of time it's gonna be
back tomorrow well yeah who knows how
much the news there will be tomorrow
what did I mean I missed a lot of [__]
today but
what are you gonna do man [__] news
everywhere just dropping everywhere I'm
staying on top of so much just in the
last
24 hours I have so many what what what
was that episode I got a [__] right
now you put them on I'm against I got
the [__] gun on Me on the clock right
now in terms of like what I got to do
with George Santos one I gotta do uh I
got to do a Donald Trump responding in
that video one and then assuming
assuming that this video or is that this
town all happens tonight I'll probably
end up having to do another one what do
you think what's your guess do you think
he shows up and says some wild crazy
[__] he's gotta show up or or what would
be even better is he releases a video
about how the fact he won't show up and
he'll say oh they were gonna sabotage me
with all these questions and try to play
victim which would make it even better
God damn everyone's calling for three
hours but Karen says Tony 24 7. holy
[__] God damn that's a that's a tall
order that's a tall order I do three
hours man I got it I do things I gotta
do to make money man I I do I do agree
that that uh three hours is almost
needed for some of these news Cycles but
we can't do it today so come back
tomorrow you know we're at same time
same place
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon